house of the dragon gives us the iron
throne we deserve
game of thrones turned the iron throne
into a pop culture icon but house of the
dragon gives us a more grandiose and
menacing version of the coveted chair
fans of the game of thrones novels and
tv series have been waiting for the
debut trailer of the long-awaited
prequel house of dragons and it finally
came
this time we're going back to the time
where westeros was ruled by house
targaryen with fire and blood
one of the most outstanding things about
the debut trailer of house of the dragon
is that we get a glimpse of the iron
throne but it looks very different from
what we remember
this royal seat is the symbol of
supremacy and now it looks more the part
it's a more faithful reflection of
george rr martin's vision so it looks a
lot more intimidating
the iron throne construction
over a century before the events of
house of dragons balerion the black
dread which was aegon the conqueror's
dragon melted one thousand blades with
his fiery breath
which was then worked on by blacksmiths
to make the iron throne
the blades were surrendered to the
targaryens by their defeated enemies in
the war of conquest so the iron throne
became a symbol of their superiority
george r.r martin has always said that
the iron throne is a mammoth of a seat
he describes it as towering over the
room and it's not necessarily aesthetic
or comfortable to sit on
it's an asymmetrical ugly beast which
makes sense considering it was made by a
dragon and blacksmiths not expert
furniture manufacturers
it's worth noting that though the house
of the dragon gives us a more
threatening version of the iron throne
it's still not exactly as described by
martin's words
if we go back to the novels the royal
seat is over 10 feet tall
so steps have to be climbed to reach it
because it's so tall it gives its
occupant a looming almost godly presence
and the sun coming from the windows and
the red keep cast a sinister shadow
the iron throne is simply frightening
and very much impractical especially
because the melted swords are still
sharp
and they poke out
additionally the fang steel behind makes
it impossible for the occupant to sit
back
the royal seat is intentionally
uncomfortable because aegon first
claimed a king should never sit easy
an evil seat
the iron throne is meant to be a visual
representation of bad vibes and
according to martin mark simonetti's
take on the royal seat truly captures
what he intended to portray in the
novels
of course the artist simonetti still
made some changes to make it more
practical for the show
but overall he captured the evil
aesthetic martin was going for
martin's work has repeatedly focused on
how impractical the structure of the
iron throne is and the effects he can
have on people's psyche
a feast for crows explains this very
well
ares the second targaryen also known as
the mad king is a great example of that
because he was essentially tormented by
the throne
the mad king was covered in half-heeled
cuts and scabs from his time on the seat
so one could say that the throne
constantly tortured him and it's not
difficult to see how it could be a
contributing factor to his madness
that madness would become the reason for
robert's rebellion which would lead to
the eventual destruction of the house
targaryen
far from game of thrones iron throne
the house of the dragons take of the
iconic seat is very different from what
we've seen on game of thrones
the version we know is a minimal
interpretation of martin's vision it's a
seat made of swords but we can say it
failed to make the right impression
it was simply too ergonomic to portray
the true evil and torturous nature of
the seat additionally it lacked the
steep stairs which were substituted for
a layered dye that was made from stone
not iron so it didn't look like a part
of the throne itself
the show was aware of these differences
leading to a kind of meta exchange
between littlefinger and varus
where littlefinger says he's counted the
swords on the throne and there aren't
even 200 of them
though the exchange may have gone over
the heads of those who hadn't read the
novels by the time the tv series aired
it served as a canonical explanation for
the differences
of course the reason behind these
differences is much simpler they didn't
have the budget in the beginning to
bring martin's vision of the iron throne
to life more accurately
especially because they had to reshoot
the pilot which put a big dent on the
budget
additionally it was just cumbersome to
make the iron throne truer to the novels
they would have had to build a larger
set for it and actors would have had to
constantly navigate around a dangerous
10-foot set piece that posed more risks
than it should
conclusion
it is very exciting to see what the
house of the dragon will do with this
more authentic representation of the
royal seat
of course the iron throne will be the
least of the character's worries in this
prequel which will focus on the internal
issues of house targaryen the demise of
the dragons and the royal civil war that
would devastate westeros
starring matt smith as prince damon
targaryen emma darcy as princess
rhaenyra targaryen and patty considine
as king viserys the first among many
others
this tv series takes place 200 years
before the events of game of thrones
and we expect it to be nothing short of
epic
though we don't know exactly when house
of the dragon will premiere just yet
because they haven't revealed the date
we can expect the first season in 2022
on hbo and hbo max hopefully it will do
the house of fire and blood justice so
stay tuned for more updates